this polynomial division business is a
little bit more fun than we expected so
let's keep going so let's say that i
guess again someone walks up to you in
the street and says what is x squared
plus 1
divided by
x plus 2. so pause this video and have a
go at that and i'll give you a little
bit of a warning this one's a little bit
more involved than you might expect
all right so there's two ways to
approach this either we can try to
re-express the numerator where it
involves an x plus two somehow or we
could try to do algebraic long division
so let me do the first way so x squared
plus 1 it's not obvious that you can
factor it out but can you
can you write something that has x plus
2 as a factor and interestingly enough
has no first degree terms because we
don't want
some first degree weird first degree
terms sitting up there and the best
thing that i could think of is
constructing a difference of squares
using x plus 2. so we know that x plus 2
times x minus 2 is equal to x squared
minus 4.
so what if we were to write x squared
minus 4 up here and then we would just
have to add five to get to plus one
so what if we were to write
x squared
minus four
and then we write plus five
this expression and that expression up
there those are completely equivalent
but why did i do that
well now i can write x squared minus 4
as
x plus 2
times x minus 2.
and so then i could rewrite this entire
expression as x plus 2
times x minus 2
all of that over
x plus 2
plus 5
plus 5
over
x plus 2
and now as long as x does not equal
negative 2 then we could divide the
numerator and the denominator by x plus
2
and then we would be left with x minus 2
plus
5
over
x plus 2 and i'll put that little
constraint if i want to say that this
expression is the same as that first
expression for x does not equal
for x not equaling negative 2.
and so here we'd say hey x squared plus
1 divided by x plus 2 is x minus 2 and
then we have a remainder of 5
remainder
of 5.
now let's do the same question or try to
rewrite this using algebraic long
division we'll see that this is actually
a little bit more straightforward
so we are going to divide
x plus 2
into
x squared plus one now when i write
things out i like to be very careful
with my i guess you could say my
different places for the different
degrees so x squared plus one has no
first degree term so i'm going to write
the one out here so
second degree no first degree term and
then we have a one which is you could
view as our zero degree term or our
constant term
and so we do the same drill how many
times does x go into x squared we just
look at the highest degree terms here x
goes into x squared x times that's first
degree so i put in the first degree
column
x times 2
is 2 x
x times x is
x squared and now we want to subtract
and so what is this going to be equal to
we know the x squareds can cancel out
and then i'm going to be subtracting
negative 2x from you could view this as
plus 0x up here
plus 1. and so you're left with negative
2x and then we bring down that 1 plus 1.
x goes into negative 2x negative 2 times
put that in the constant
column negative 2 times 2 is negative 4
and then negative 2 times x is negative
2x now we have to be very careful here
because we want to subtract the negative
2x minus 4 from the negative 2x plus 1.
we could view it as this or we could
just distribute the negative sign
and then this would be positive 2x plus
4 and then
the two x's the 2x and the negative 2x
cancels out 1 plus 4 is 5 and there's no
obvious way of dividing x plus 2 into 5
so we would call that the remainder
exactly what we had before when we
divided with algebraic long division we
got x minus 2 x minus 2 with a remainder
of five